welcome back to New rockstars I'm
Whitney van laningham and black panther
wakanda forever set designer Hannah
beechler recently tweeted out several
images that give us a closer look at
talocon's intricate Decor her
explanations diagrams and insight add a
lot more to nemour's backstory and today
I'm breaking down some details that
beechler tells us we might have missed
this first image shows nemour's
establishment story her beachler's tweet
and the attention to detail is
incredible but to fully understand the
influences behind this image we have to
dive into some ancient Maya culture
first just a heads up I may pronounce
some words wrong and I'm very sorry but
it's my birthday this weekend so legally
you're not allowed to get mad at me
another one of her tweets says that
talocon's establishment story was based
on the history of Palenque a
medium-sized Maya state in Chiapas
Mexico that died out in the 8th Century
Palenque was known for its beautiful
architecture sculptures boss relief
carvings and roof Combs aka the
structures that top a pyramid in
Mesoamerican culture which each had a
specific meaning to the Mayans in
wakanda Forever the talocons themselves
come from Palenque so it's no surprise
that their underwater architecture is so
stunning and intricate each layer's
designs were also inspired by knich
janab pakalda first the most famous
ruler of kalenke known as pakal the
great he was only 12 years old when he
became kahul bakalaja or the Divine Lord
of Palenque and ruled until he was 68.
bakal was responsible for the
construction and extension of palenque's
most notable surviving inscriptions and
architecture which were largely
discovered intact and legible when the
city-state was excavated his own tomb
inscription became a hot topic of debate
back in 2009 with Ancient Aliens
truthers claiming that it shows an image
of pacal being sucked up into a UFO but
that's false historians believe this
shows his descent to the underworld that
image is also inspired by the tablet
from the Temple of the foliated cross
one of the three temples that comprise
the cross-complex in Palenque the cross
Motif is a representation of the world
tree a popular myth in Mesoamerican
Indo-European Siberian American Indian
and other cultures it states that a
gigantic tree is responsible for holding
up the Heavens connecting them to the
terrestrial Earth and the underworld at
the Temple of the Cross boss release if
carvings depict another Maya King
nichecon belam's rise to the throne of
Palenque although historians used to
think that the bigger guy in the image
was convalam and the smaller guy was
pakal they now believe that one image
shows balam as a Young Man following the
Rites of Passage and the other an older
balam ascending to the throne here in
bishler's image we see a younger nemour
wearing land-based clothing as the heir
to the throne of talocon and an older no
more wearing water-based clothing as
their King beechler said in her tweet no
more transcends from boy to a job he
stands on land as a boy then on shark is
a job Young no more is holding a
bloodletting device made of a stingray
spine and sea feathers which is likely
part of his rite of passage similar to
the way that balam's younger self was
depicted older nemour is holding a
pseudobombox idol and dear God I hope
I'm pronouncing that word right these
plants are also known as the Dr Seuss
tree and they're native to Southern
Mexico they're most commonly used to
carve handicrafts like this Idol here
The Conch symbols in this drawing are
actually the emblem of quetzacotal and
his disguise as the wind God and we're
also a luxury object for the ruling
Elites of mesoamerica below we see a
shark which was interesting only
commonly depicted in Mayan art despite
many of their states being located
Inland nowhere near the ocean many
historians believe that these Inland
Mayas got into the shark tooth trade
with others living by the coast as
intact shark teeth were also found
during excavations of these regions but
in nemour's case we know exactly why
there's a little short guy here we all
got pretty comfy talking to one another
through screens over the past few years
right people can see you and they can
hear you but they can't smell you which
is great when it comes to see people
face to face you're going to want to
make sure that the way you smell is a
choice and not an afterthought oh
brother this guy stinks and that's where
scentbird comes in Sanford is a fragrant
subscription service so it's the perfect
place to begin or deep in your
relationship with fragrances they're
reimagining everything about how to
discover shop for purchase and even
experience fragrances semford lets you
choose a new designer fragrance to try
every month for just 17 and every month
you get to pick what you want to receive
so there are no surprises they have
perfumes and colognes and a ton of
unisex options with each fragrance
you'll get a 30 day supply so you can
try out fragrances before committing to
a full-size bottle scentbird carries
Brands like Prada Gucci Versace as well
as Indie labels like Skyler heretic and
confessions of Rebel your fragrance is
an opportunity to express your
individuality and simproid selection
gives each and every person the power to
express themselves through fragrance
this month stampford sent me purple noon
by asovert Neroli and Acacia by scents
of wood and Draco by tiziana turenzi you
know which one should I do I'm going to
choose this one because it smells like a
boy and I want to smell like a man and
we get spritzed
foreign
[Applause]
Acacia it's got these bright notes of
citrus that poke out of a gentle blanket
of Oaky Woody goodness it makes me feel
like I'm at a wedding that's classy and
everything I say is witty and well
received that's the vibe of this smell
and it's a good vibe if you're in the US
or Canada you can get started finding
your fragrance with scent bird for just
a little over seven dollars for your
first month click the link in the
description below and use coupon code
new rockstars 55 for 55 off thanks to
semford for sponsoring this video check
out the links in the description to
learn more water lilies were also
commonly depicted in Mesoamerican art as
a symbol of the life-giving force of
water at the center we see a large
Calabash tree which was mentioned in the
Popova aka the oldest written Mayan myth
in history beechler cites the hero twins
as an inspiration as well they were two
twins who popped up a lot in The
Narrative of the Popova and famously
defeated the Lords of the Underworld in
an ancient baseball game fun fact Miguel
and Tulio were pretending to be these
guys in The Road to El Dorado at the
bottom right you can see an owl
messenger of the underworld who saved
the hero twins Mother after her father
tried to slut-shame her to death the
Twins were eventually turned into the
Moon and Sun and beachler wanted that
imagery as an homage to Ryan coogler and
his daughter beechler also tweeted that
the placement of nemour's Throne Room on
set corresponded with the four
directions from Mayan culture symbolized
in four glyphs that stood for the north
south east and west the throne room in
wakanda Forever is set up to honor the
four directions showing The Conch of the
Moon North The Conch of the day sun east
the Concha Venus South and The Conch of
the night West the glyphs in each Corner
correspond with text from the book of
chalambalam a handwritten collection of
important traditional Maya knowledge and
described the setting up of world trees
in the four directions in the north the
white tree was raised in the East a blue
green tree in the south of yellow tree
and a black tree in the west these
colors correspond to those of the
cardinal directions in Maya culture as
well lastly at the center we also see
images of the Sun God and the moon
goddess viewing the former as the
masculine ruler of the earth and the
latter is the feminine contrast to his
Celestial realm my favorite of these
tweets is the napkin drawing the
beachler sent out hide that [ __ ] from
Edward Norton Hannah on it we see her
original idea for no More's massive
Megalodon jaw throne and no that big ass
12 feet by 10 feet thing wasn't CGI it
was actually made and carved with a
hieroglyphic in the bone that reads this
Jade tooth bites many Mayans actually
use Jade itself as a carving tool so
these Jade teeth are made to really
Hammer home that this shark could have
really [ __ ] you up in its lifetime
knowing that many of these scenes were
actually filmed in underwater tanks in
the studio makes the size and detail of
set pieces like this one all the more
impressive finally let's look at the
design on the bottom of no more spear on
it beachler included Nemours Cannon
labeled imperious wrecks in this drawing
imperius Rex is what no more shouts in
the comics before jumping into battle
and means Empire King Loosely translated
from Latin in Marvel Comics this Battle
Cry serves as a warning to the
submariner's opponents kinda like this
terrifyingly sharp and dangerous spear
does follow me on Instagram and Twitter
at whitneypuppy follow new Rockstar
subscribe to me rockstars for more
analysis of everything you love and
thanks for watching bye
[Music]
thank you